we have zofran talking about amp for
orthogonally invariant models
uh thank you very much alex for the
introduction um thanks to jamming and
pulling and lauren for the invitation to
come speak thank you all for coming
so today i'll talk about approximate
message passing or amp algorithms this
will be a part of this will be joint
work with two wonderful phd students
working with me tian hao wong and shin
yi chong
at els nds
and also with my colleague who's here in
the audience today
um
okay so uh we heard a lot about amp um
throughout the course of this semester
and applications of this and cindy gave
a nice tutorial about this at the boot
camp
so i'll be brief in my introduction
what i'll mean by an amp algorithm in
this talk is something of the following
form
we're given a symmetric matrix w which
is n by n
and starting from some initialization u1
and rn
what i'll mean by an amp algorithm is
any iterative procedure
that takes your iterate u multiplies by
w
subtracts a correction of bias from this
product and then we call this the biased
iterative z
and then taking all the iterations z
that i've seen so far apply a non-linear
function to this to get the next u right
so amp refers to a broad class of these
kinds of algorithms
this nonlinear function that we can
apply in every iteration can be quite
general and this has allowed amp to be
designed to do
optimization or statistical inference in
a number of different applications
and what's special about amp what makes
it amp is this definition of the bias
correction in every iterate or the
onsagger correction
this is carefully defined to ensure that
the algorithm has a very special
property
that every one of these z iterates
empirically looks like a gaussian
distribution so if i look at the
empirical distribution coordinates of z
in the large system limit as n goes to
infinity this has a limiting gaussian
law
and this law is described by what's
called the amp state evolution
okay so in some sense the ideas behind
amp uh originated maybe with um
the work of thalis anderson and palmer
uh who wrote down a mean field equation
for the sk model
and this was operationalized into an
iterative algorithm by bolt housing
and in the statistics and learning
literature
the first examples of amp algorithms
were developed for applications of
bayesian linear regression compressed
sensing sparse linear regression
and since then amp has found application
to a very large number of different
problems and applications right so
problems of robust regression
glms logistic regression phase retrieval
pca group synchronization and the list
goes on
and it's it's really an incredible body
of literature that's
been developed many of this by people in
this community and people here in the
audience today
so i think
one of the main appeals of amp is this
uh is this fact that the iterates of
this algorithm have a very clean and
simple asymptotic characterization uh
this is often what makes the algorithm
useful
um
from the perspective of algorithm design
what this lets you do
is to closely design or tailor each of
these non-linear functions that you
apply to the specific distribution of
its inputs
and from the perspective of theoretical
analysis it allows amp to serve as a
theoretical tool for studying the high
dimensional asymptotics of statistical
procedures of nonlinear procedures
the general way in which this might work
is you have some statistical estimator
that you're interested in characterizing
asymptotically
and if you can design an amp algorithm
that converges to this estimator
then because you can characterize every
iterative a and p this allows you to
characterize the estimator itself right
and this is a strategy that's been used
over and over again and the in the
papers that i had on the preceding slide
however so this this benefit of amp it
does come
with what i think is a pretty strong
assumption which is that this
characterization requires an assumption
about the distribution of this matrix w
on which you're applying the algorithm
and most commonly this assumption is an
assumption that w has iid entries up to
its symmetry
so
of course we can study a lot of very
interesting and rich probabilistic and
statistical models where you do have id
data of this form
but i think it does represent a
limitation
in particular if we start thinking about
applications of amp to
statistical settings where this matrix w
is supposed to represent real data be a
model for our data that we observe
uh this assumption can become uh
problematic and this is sort of
uh the motivation that brought us down
this line of work
so what i want to tell you about today
is one direction in which we can think
about trying to weaken this assumption
it's a direction where informally you
can think about it as
still requiring w to have generic
eigenvectors but allowing the eigenvalue
spectrum of this matrix w to be
arbitrary
and more formally it's it's a setting
where we're going to assume that w is
orthogonal or rotationally invariant in
law
there's been a line of work on amp
algorithms in this kind of a setting and
what i'll talk about today is one such
algorithm
so here's the outline for uh the rest of
the talk for most of the talk today i'm
going to just actually
talk about amp and the abstract and talk
about the general form of this algorithm
without
making reference to a specific
application this is sort of house indeed
to the tutorial back a few months ago
and then closer to the end of the talk
i'll try to tell maybe two shorter
vignettes about applications in which
you can use such an algorithm one will
be a statistical application to beijing
pca
and the second will be a probabilistic
application to study a spin-less model
and feel free to interrupt with any
questions as we
go okay so let me uh start with a and p
uh the general amp algorithm orthogonal
uh matrices
um so before doing this let me maybe
just remind you concretely what is the
form of the usual amp for iid matrices
uh it's an algorithm of the form i
stated earlier where uh this debiasing
uh this bias correction that you
subtract and every iteration is a linear
combination of your previous iterates u1
through ut minus one
right
and then in every iteration we're
applying a nonlinear function that i'm
calling here the uh non-bold-faced
u t plus one
and in this talk i'm going to consider
just the so-called separable setting
where this function is a function of a
low dimensional input applied to every
coordinate of these vectors
so the definition of the de-biasing and
the state evolution in the standard amp
algorithm you can describe it in terms
of two t by t matrices up to an
iteration t
the first matrix is a matrix of average
derivatives of these functions i take
every single one of these nonlinear
functions u i've applied up to now i
look at every derivative in each of its
coordinates and i average this across
the entries of the matrix
all right and i collect this into a t by
t object then we're going to call phi
and then the second
t by t matrix that'll be relevant for us
is is the
empirical second moment matrix of these
iterates u right so it's the normalized
inner product between us and ut for
iterates i've seen up to now and i'll
collect this into a t by t matrix called
delta
and so in the standard form of amp for
iid matrices the forms of the device and
coefficients that you need to use to
ensure this gaussian property
is to take the entries of this this
linear combination as the entries of
this derivative matrix phi all right so
bts in this blue expression would just
be phi ts
if you choose the divising coefficients
in this way then the basic result about
amp
in the type of algorithm i just
described would be one due to uh java
martin montanari in 2013
where the covariance of this gaussian
law is described exactly by delta or
more precisely the limit of delta as n
goes to infinity
so if i call sigma this limit then the
statement is that if w has iid entries
which are gaussian up to the symmetry of
w
and each of these nonlinear functions u
that you apply is lipschitz
then um if your input vector to a and p
this u1
its empirical law converges weakly and
let's say washerstein 2 to some limit l
as n goes to infinity then when you look
at your iterative z1 through zt up to
any fixed iteration t of the algorithm
that is also going to have an empirical
law right so the coordinates of z1
through zt as n goes to infinity will
converge to a to a t-dimensional
multivariate gaussian the mean will be
zero
and the covariance is exactly the limit
of the second moment matrix delta
and so this is the kind of guarantee
that you would get for amp it's the
state evolution description of the
limiting law of the uterus
okay
and it's understood that this algorithm
and this result uh holds over a larger
universality class of matrices we don't
need the the normality assumption um
there's work by bayati lelaja montanari
who extend this to the universality
class of matrices with iid sub-gaussian
entries
but what i want to talk to you about
today is a model that falls outside of
this universality class right
so the model that i want to consider is
a model where w is rotationally
invariant in law
and what this means is that if i were to
write down the eigen decomposition of w
as o transpose times lambda times o
then o would be a random
har uniform orthogonal matrix of
eigenvectors so in this sense the
eigenvectors are generic and uniformly
random
and lambda is a diagonal matrix of
eigenvalues
where i'm essentially i'm going to allow
lambda to converge empirically to any
limiting distribution which i'll call
capital lambda
as n goes to infinity for simplicity
here i'm assuming it's compactly
supported
okay
and the main result that i want to
describe
is that in this context there is an amp
algorithm of basically the same general
form
that continues to ensure that these
iterates z1 z2 et cetera have this
empirical gaussian limit
the coefficients that you need to use in
the de-biasing need to be adjusted
they're different from the ones of
standard amp
and the covariance of this limiting
gaussian will also be different and
these will depend on the spectral limit
on the law of lambda
and this algorithm and this result was
first arrived non-rigorously in work by
oprah chukmakinvinter in 2015
and i'll come back to the starvation in
a second
but let me first show you the form of
the algorithm
so the dependence of the uh devising
coefficients on this limiting law lambda
is um
through uh what are called the free
cumulants of this limiting law i'm
denoting these three cumulants as
capital one kappa two et cetera uh these
are a certain set of numbers they're
defined from the moments of lambda
through uh what are called the
non-crossing moment cumulative relations
or
it's a set of relations on the
non-crossing partition lattice
uh equivalently they're the coefficients
and the series expansion of the r
transform of this object lambda right so
r of z is a generating function if you
will where the cumulatives are the
coefficients of this generating function
and the devising coefficients that you
need to use in amp to ensure this
gaussian limit
are not the entries of this derivative
matrix phi itself necessarily but of the
entries of the r transform of lambda
applied to phi
and you can interpret this spectrally or
as defined by this this infinite series
okay
um and if if okay so in the example
where w has iid normal zero one over n
entries
uh the limiting empirical uh
spectral distribution of this noise w
would be vigner semicircle law
this is the distribution that has the
trivial cumulative sequence zero one
zero zero zero zero et cetera
and in this case our phi would just be
phi and so the biasing recovers the
devising of standard amp
so if you set the division coefficients
in this way
then the main guarantee is the one that
you see here which is analogous to this
result of java martin montanari that i
just showed
suppose each function ut is lipschitz
and this empirical distribution of the
eigenvalues of w converges to this limit
lambda weekly
and let me suppose that the minimum and
maximum eigenvalues converge to the
edges of the support
then again if your initialization of amp
has a limiting law
uh in a vascular stein two sense
uh then your your iterates z1 z2 etc
through zt will continue to have this
limiting gaussian law right with some uh
with mean zero and sum limit covariance
sigma
uh and the form of sigma is also a
little bit different from standard amp
it's a little bit more complicated what
sigma should look like you can also
define in terms of an infinite series of
matrices where the coefficients of the
series are the free cumulants of this
limit spectral law
and the terms of this series are certain
polynomials in this derivative matrix
phi and the second moment matrix delta
okay
so in the case where w has iid gaussian
entries
again the series just consists of a
single term of the sum and you recover
this
this isometry and in usual amp that
sigma is just the limit of delta
okay so let me uh so i won't go through
a proof of this result um but i think
it's it's really a magical
the form of the algorithm is really it's
magical to me um
and i think the first kind of question
that uh you would ask is sort of where
does the r transform or where do these
free cumulatives come from why do they
arise
um and so i want to give two uh
i'll try to give two answers to this
question in this talk today
uh the first is that um okay i'll try to
explain at a high level what is the way
in which this algorithm was derived by
oprah chuck mcinvinter
this was using the so-called dynamic
functional theory approach
in this approach so we're trying to
characterize the law of z1 through zt
we write down a characteristic function
for these vectors so the characteristic
function is a function of arguments l1
through lt
and you see this
this complex exponential term defining
the characteristic function
it's integrated over dummy variables u
and z corresponding to the amp iterates
and the relations between the iterates
of a and p are encoded by direct delta
functions that describe how theaters
evolve over iterations right
and this outer expectation here is an
expectation over this random matrix w or
the disorder
so what we want to do is to evaluate
this expectation and take the limit
um
and and to do this in this dynamic
functional theory approach you can do it
by representing the second delta
function involving w
using a fourier integral it's a fourier
representation of the delta
and after doing this representation i
can take this expectation over this
order w inside the two integrals
and if i do this what i need to end up
evaluating is an expectation of a
product of exponentials of e to the i
this is the dummy variable that's
introduced in this fourier integral
transpose
w ut
and this you can you can write uh
by pushing everything into the
exponential and cycling trace you can
write it as an hci z integral over this
horizontal randomness
uh and taking the limit as n goes to
infinity using a saddle point
calculation the limit of this hcis
integral is going to give you the r
transform of lambda
so this is one explanation for why the r
transform emerges in this algorithm
so as far as i know i don't know if this
can be directly turned into a rigorous
proof of amp i haven't seen it done
and so the second explanation i want to
give for where the free humans come from
is through our rigorous derivation
and the rigorous proof that we give
is using this
by now a well-established idea for how
you prove it these amp results which is
to use this iterative um or inductive
conditioning argument that uh
was used by bolt housing and bayati
montanari in the early work on amp
and in the context of this kind of
rotationally ovarian model it was used
also
in the vector amp paper by rangan
schnitzer and fletcher
the basic idea is the following i want
to condition on the iterates of a and p
up to some iteration t
in order to analyze the distribution of
the next
t plus one in the orthogonal context the
set of things you want to condition on
are u and then also o times u as well as
z okay
now if you try to do this iterative
conditioning argument and you sort of
work out the calculation of what what
you need to know about you
uh to understand the distribution of zt
plus one uh it it turns out that it's
not enough to just know what is the
limiting empirical law of u you you need
more information and so the the limit
distribution of z t plus one
uh ends up depending on uh quadratic
forms of the type that you see here
uh they're quadratic forms defined by u
and then some power of w where this
power can be zero one or two
okay um and then now if you want to do
an induction you want to ask okay up to
it or a t for these quadratic forms what
do these in turn depend on update or t
minus one
and these will depend on the same kinds
of quadratic forms or the power of w can
now be zero one two three or four
and then the dependence on it or t minus
two is is these quadratic forms where
the power goes up to six
all the way down and the final
dependents are just quadratic forms
defined by your amp initialization u1
um where the power of w uh can go all
the way up to 2t if you're analyzing
your routine
so this last layer of objects these last
quadratic forms here are very easy to
understand because our initialization in
amp u1 is independent of w and w is
orthogonally invariant in law so this
will be approximately just the
normalized trace of w to the k
which has the limit the kth moment of
the empirical spectral limit law right
so at this bottom layer what you're
going to get are the moments of the
limit eigenvalue
distribution and then somehow
the emergence of the free humans comes
from how these moments are attracted
through the layers of this induction
right we go up and up through the layers
induction and finally they become the
free cumulatives
and so this this analysis is enabled by
uh the following structural lemma which
tracks these moments so the dilemma is
the following
that if i fix any two iterations u
and i look at this type of quadratic
form defined by the kth power of w
this has a well characterized limit in
the large system limit as n goes to
infinity
where this is given by the entries of
yet another series
in these matrices theta so these are the
same matrices theta that define the
covariance of the emp state evolution
and the coefficients of this series are
combinatorial objects that interpolate
between the moments and the free
cumulants of the spectral law
and to be a little bit more precise
about what these are they have the
following definition
if i denote by nckl the set of
non-crossing partitions of the numbers 1
through k
where no element of the set belongs to
just the first l numbers 1 through l
it's a subset of this non-crossing
partition lattice
then these numbers ckl or ck minus ll
are defined as partial sums over the
subset of the non-crossing partition
lattice
of products of the free cumulus
so if i take l equals 0 here what i get
is the sum of the entire lattice which
is defining the moment cumulative
relations behind these objects so ck0
would just be the moments of the
spectral law and then as you vary k and
l you get this two-dimensional
interpolation of numbers essentially
between the moments and the humans and
these are used to characterize these
intermediate
quadratic forms that you need an
inductive argument
perhaps i should just
comment that
so in the case when you have iid entries
and you're just looking at the usual amp
algorithm
uh the free cumulants of this limit law
which is the finger semicircle law is a
trivial sequence but these intermediate
numbers are i think non-trivial
combinatorial objects and this is
characterizing some limit
um that i think is interesting even in
the case of the standard amp algorithm
for gaussian matrices
uh and let me uh to close this section
of talk just
make
a final comment about the structure or
specialization of this algorithm that
would connect it a little bit more to uh
some other algorithms of this type in
the literature
so this algorithm simplifies in a
particular setting that you can call a
memory free setting
it's a setting where i normalize my
matrix w so that this limit spectral law
has mean zero and variance one
and then i choose these nonlinear
functions in a special way i choose them
so that the average derivatives of these
functions all converge to zero so it's a
so-called divergence free condition
uh and if you design your algorithm in
this way
then first of all the limit of this
matrix b with the debian coefficients is
zero so you actually don't need to apply
any debian amp to preserve the
gaussianity of the iterates
and then this isometry that sigma is the
limit of delta that you see in standard
amp would be preserved in this setting
and this setting would be quite similar
to the
vector amp algorithm and the orthogonal
and unitary amp algorithms that have
been developed for
linear models and generalized linear
models in the context of orthogonal
variance
okay and then a second sort of also kind
of magical to the
simplification that arises when you
consider this kind of memory-free
algorithm
is that the iterates of amp actually
maintain a certain asymptotic freeness
property with w
and i can characterize in the following
way if i take any smooth bounded
function f
i apply it spectrally to this matrix w
and i consider the quadratic form
defined by u
this limit behaves as if the u's were
independent of w so this is definitely
true for the initialization of a and p
but this properly continues to hold in
even all of the remaining iterates of
amp
so it's in some sense saying that these
iterates u are asymptotically free of w
is something special that happens in
this memory free case
you can derive this quite easily from
the dilemma i just had by just
considering uh f to be um x to the k
like a polynomial right if you consider
f to be x to the k this is exactly the
kind of thing we characterize in the
preceding lemma and you can check that
this is the result that pops out and
then
if you get it for all polynomials you
can get it for all smooth functions by a
polynomial approximation
so it's a second
i think very interesting structure of
these memory free algorithms
okay so let me transition maybe then to
describe um two applications of this
algorithm
uh the first will be a statistical
application to uh bayesian pca and this
is with my students uh shenytron and tia
halwa so the setting that i want to
study then is the following uh i want to
consider a recovery of a low rank signal
in the in the spiked signal plus noise
model right so let me consider a
data matrix y
that is the sum of a rank k signal
component symmetric let's say plus some
observational noise uh w
um and the assumptions that i want to
make are that
so the the the coordinates of these
signals the rows of the signal matrix
are distributed
from some
k dimensional prior distribution on rk
and the assumption that i want to make
for the noise is that it has an
arbitrary spectral profile so i don't
want to assume that this noise is id
and i think it's helpful to maybe just
have in mind um to two pictures to make
this a bit more concrete
so so these pictures um
are taken from a single cell gene
expression example
where uh what i'm showing you is a pca
analysis essentially of a gene
expression matrix
uh the plot on the left is a bivariate
scatter plot of the top two principal
components in this data
um and so you if you imagine that k
equals two
then um the structure that you see in
this picture would be this
two-dimensional prior that i'm
describing here for the signal
components in r2 right
uh and then if we make a scatter plot of
uh the singular values okay so so this
would be a rectangular setting which is
slightly different from what i'm talking
about but
if i make a scatter plot of the singular
values of the noise in this data
what you see is this histogram in blue
here
and the phenomenon that we observe is
that there's an over dispersion of these
singular values compared to
uh what you would expect if it were
truly white noise right so if w really
had iid
entries then this distribution would be
the square root of a marchenko pester
law which is this curve shown in orange
and what you see and what i think is
quite common in data applications is
some over dispersion of the spectral
distribution
presumably due to correlations between
genes and between cells of this data set
so this is in some sense that the the uh
motivation that originally drove uh our
group to start thinking about this
problem
um
the behavior so the random matrix side
of things the the spectral understanding
of this model uh is by now classical uh
there's a paper by benay george and nata
gudity in 2009 that characterized
the spectral behavior in this model so
bbp type phase transitions and
alignments of
the sample eigenvectors with the ground
truth
and the question that i want to ask is
uh can we design an amp algorithm to to
perform a more bayesian style of
inference if i have prior structure on a
pc sorry so this is the kind of
application that's been
studied quite extensively in the setting
of iid noise
okay so uh we we proposed the following
kind of approach
so the algorithm that i've described up
to now can be uh extended so in this
work with shin yiti hal
we extended the algorithm to work with
um k dimensional areas essentially
instead of just vector value iterates so
we can have an amp algorithm whose
iterates are of dimension m by k
and you can initialize this algorithm
spectrally using the top k sample pieces
of this matrix y
and then the form of the amp algorithm
would be basically exactly the same as
what i described earlier right except in
this sort of k-dimensional space
um and this this kind of extension is
sort of completely analogous to the
extension that was obtained by uh
andreia and ramji in in 2017 for this
application with iid noise
the forms of the debian in this
algorithm are a bit different from what
i described previously to you and i
won't put their specific forms in this
talk
they still depend on the spectral law of
the noise through the free cumulants of
that law
but they also have a dependence on the
signal strengths in this model
and this is due to the spectral
initializations due to the fact that i'm
initializing at the sample pcs rather
than at an independent initialization
so in the setting a result that we can
state about the state evolution of such
an algorithm is the following
suppose in addition to these uh this
orthogonally invariant assumption for w
that the
signal component so let me call this x
star which is an m by k matrix of the
lowering signal uh this converges weakly
in a vascular stein 2 to a limit law
x star sorry it's hard to
distinguish um and then uh suppose that
each signal eigenvalue uh
exceeds um a certain lambda dependent
signal strength so this is a technical
requirement that we need in the result
uh then the result is that for suitably
defined uh mean transformation mu and
covariance sigma the joint distribution
of the ground truth x star with these
amp eater is z
will converge weakly and a vascular sign
two to a limit
where the limit of the z's is a
transformation of x star now it's not
mean zero it has some dependence on the
signal
uh plus plus gaussian noise okay
and
okay i think the simplest way that you
can think about
designing this kind of algorithm and how
we do the proof is that you can imagine
the spectrum the spectral initialization
itself is the outcome of a long sequence
of linear amp iterates that carry out
some power method iteration and converge
to this initialization this is a
strategy that was introduced by mondeli
and venkataramanan in 2020
and they applied it also to a rank one
setting of this model recently this year
okay so i haven't told you what are the
nonlinear functions to apply
and what we suggest
is the following so i have the state
evolution description of the joint law
of x star and all my preceding iterative
z
to implement some kind of a bayesian
estimation uh what we suggest is to take
the base posterior mean denoiser you
take the expectation of x star
conditional on all of your preceding
iterates z0 through zt according to this
prescribed joint law
this is slightly different from what's
usually done for amp applications to id
noise what's usually done is that you
take just
the posterior mean conditional on the
single preceding iterate zt it has a
dependence only on the previous iterate
and you can check actually that when
when lambda is the semicircle law so
when this is an id application these two
approaches are equivalent
and they're equivalent because of a
conditional independent structure that
arises between x star and z zero through
z t minus one given z t this arises from
the amp isometry of sigma and delta in
standard amp
for general uh distributions of the
spectral noise these approaches are not
the same so these are two different
algorithms
and when these are not the same
i think there are some advantages to
using this full posterior mean denoiser
uh coming from the fact that these would
form a martingale so because the
sequence forms a martingale this would
ensure for example that the asymptotic
mean squared error of the amphitheater
is actually improved over iterations
and it can also just immediately
guarantee that the state evolution of
this algorithm is convergent
i'll show you uh one quick example
before moving to
a second application so this is one
example that we did in simulation
where we simulated a rank one signal
having uh rademacher plus one minus one
entries either the signal components the
prior on my signal
and then the noise we wanted to simulate
something that's non-white so we
simulated the noise from a beta 3 1
distribution appropriately centered and
scaled
the reason why we chose beta 3 1 is
because for this noise distribution
there's no spectral phase transition so
there's no bbp type transition
the spikes become supercritical once
theta becomes positive in this model
and so this is the uh the the error of
pca starts to become non-trivial even
for very small theta
so what you're seeing in this plot
is a comparison of the estimation error
of this rank 1 signal in gray is the
curve for uh just standard pca
in red is the curve for this bayes amp
algorithm that just described to you
right
and what i'm comparing this to also
is the estimation error of an approach
where you only denoise with respect to
the single preceding iterate this is in
blue
and then this very brief curve in green
that you see here is what happens if you
just naively apply the gaussian amp
algorithm to this to to this model to
this data
right so what this is showing is a plot
of the
estimation error against the strength of
the signal this parameter theta
so what you see is that uh this bayes
omp algorithm seems to give a consistent
uh improvement over standard pca for all
values of the signal strength
uh and it improves also over the uh
single iterate than the galaxy and emp
approaches the reason this gaussian
curve is so short is because
we're applying procedures to estimate
all of the parameters empirically from
the data so the strengths of the signal
and the free cumulatives everything is
estimated empirically
and we're using a gaussian-based theory
to estimate the signal strength which
requires some phase transition threshold
for theta
so when that
becomes
uh inapplicable we sort of stop the
curve
here you use subspace distance so what's
the
decision
that's a good question i don't remember
it i think it maybe is the operator norm
of the difference between the rank one
projections
i see
the maximum value is one yeah that makes
sense
okay
[Music]
sorry how do
how do you do the estimation that's sort
of lots of parameters how do you
estimate the uh the
yeah um
they're sort of standard approaches okay
so you can estimate the signal strength
theta through the spectral theory so the
results of banitex georgia nautical tt
derived sort of the bias of the
eigenvalues and so we can estimate the
true signal strengths from the sample
eigenvalues that you observe
the frequency of the spectral law we
just compute to the empirical spectral
distribution remove maybe in this case
the top eigenvalue
uh compute its empirical moments and
pass them through the moment
accumulations and get the free cumulants
and then all of the devising
coefficients and all of the uh state
evolution parameters are then computed
from these things
yeah so everything is empirical the only
thing we're not empirically estimating
in this example is the prior on the
signal i'm assuming i know it's erotic
or plus one minus one prior
just to clarify oh sorry
uh the the algorithm the coefficients
only depend on the bulk
right so you can just compute the bulk
of the observed um listen no so when you
look at
when you do the pca initialization these
uh these the biasing coefficients end up
uh end up depending also on the signal
strength data uh-huh and then that one
you can learn from the top eigenvalues
yeah you can estimate them because i see
i see okay all right thank you uh in in
a supercritical we're assuming
everything so
uh i'm assuming that each theta is
larger than a lambda dependent constant
and inheriting this is that it's in a
supercritical regime for the model
so i i just had a question so um
i was trying to understand the
relationship to like the vector
approximate message passing with the
right orthogonally invariant model yeah
sure so like in this example with that
histogram
if we just assumed the right orthogonal
variant
noise would it not
like
i mean
could we have used vamp on this problem
i guess and
um
yeah yeah there's a lot to unpack in
your questions so okay i don't know i'm
trying to uh this is a symmetric setting
so i guess you know it's but if you
consider a rectangular setting you can
consider both left and right
orthogonally invariant models
um for pc i mean in vamp because you
sort of naturally have you know a
transpose a everywhere so it doesn't
really require anything about the left
orthogonal variance i think it would be
natural in rectangular versions of this
problem to consider variance on both
sides
the question about whether you can apply
a vamp or some damp style algorithm to
do this denoising i'm not sure
um
partly
because well i don't know if this is
superficial or not but uh
you know vamp operates on a resolvent of
this matrix which would be w here but
here we only observe it with the signal
spike
and if i were to naively compute a
resolvent of y i think it becomes
complicated because i would invert also
the spike component
yeah so i've spent some time before
thinking about whether it's possible to
develop a vamp style algorithm this
problem and i'm not sure at the moment
okay
thanks
one more question yeah another
realistic estimator i have in mind is
the mle
and the mle right dml
your noise here is correlated but it
seems that we can still write down the
likelihood and try to minimize the
likelihood yeah
and do you think that the the amp method
will beat uh mle or not yeah i'm not i'm
not sure
it's a good question i'm not sure so i
guess that would completely ignore the
prior structure maybe on your spikes
unless something that's right yes so
then i think you know intuitively you
kind of if your application has very
strong prior structure you really want
to use that prior to do your denoising
that's where a lot of the gain is going
to come from
but the question about uh yeah so it's
slightly different from likelihood
approaches um
one thing that's different in this
orthogonal variant model is that when
you write down the likelihood it's not a
quadratic likelihood because w is not
gaussian
sure for example it should have you know
some potential defining w it would be
the trace of this potential
of y minus the spike so it becomes a
pretty complicated likelihood so i'm not
sure it's the sensitive question
sure
because the pca basically assume it's an
mle type of algorithm by assuming the w
has id gaussian entries
so it's real so it's expected that pci
is not as good
yeah thanks
[Music]
hey
uh if not uh i think i have five minutes
maybe let me talk about a second
application
so i'll talk about a second
probabilistic application this is joint
work with ehong
and this is to a model of spinglasses
so let me consider an easing model with
external field
uh the hamiltonian of this model has two
terms a quadratic interaction term
defined by a couplings matrix w and then
a linear term defined by this external
field vector h
beta is the inverse temperature and is
defined on the hypercube
so if w has iid gaussian entries this
would be the sk model with external
field
so this kind of orthogonally invariant
amp algorithm lets you study
a more general setting of this kind of
model if you will where instead of
assuming that w has iid entries let's
assume that it's orthogonally invariant
in law right so the eigenvectors of w
are random and hard uniform
and the eigenvalues can be arbitrary
they converge weakly and strongly to
this limit lambda
okay and for the external field let me
assume that also the empirical
distribution of this external fuel
vector converges to
a limit h
so for this model in the high
temperature regime of this model there
are two related predictions from physics
the first is that the free energy or one
over n times the log partition function
uh has the so-called replica symmetric
limit that you see here
this limit if it depends on an
asymptotic overlap parameter q star
and it depends also on the spectral law
of this couplings matrix
w through again the r transform of the
spectral law
so this uh form was first uh derived
using the replica method by uh marinara
parisian return to 94 for
a special setting of this model known as
the random orthogonal model or rom
and this computation was extended by
sharia dna lefevre
and the second related conjecture in
this model is that if i were to look at
the mean of this distribution
this mean satisfies a modification of
the usual tap equation for sk
where in this tap equation instead of
your beta squared 1 minus q star you
have a term that depends also on the r
transform of the spectral law of the
couplings
and this type equation was first derived
using the so-called leftist expansion
approach by parisian potters in 95
and it was rederived using a cavity
method argument in the adaptive tap
paper of oprah vinter and o1
where they extended this also to this
entire orthogonal invariant family so
praising potters did it for the rom as
well
okay so using this amp uh machinery with
ehong what we were able to do is to to
say some things about the first of these
two things
um so we were able to show that uh in a
regime of sufficiently high temperature
so for small enough beta uh the limit of
the log partition function is indeed
this replica symmetric prediction almost
surely
this result for no external field was
shown previously by uh shibo and bashar
al-batacharya using a second moment
calculation
and our proof for the presence of an
external field where h does not equal to
zero it combines um a conditional second
moment idea that was introduced by
volatiles and for sk
with an analysis of an amp algorithm
that solves the prezi potter's type
equations and this was introduced by
chuck martin over
okay so let me try to explain these two
uh components of this proof before
wrapping up
so the conditional second moment idea is
the following
uh at sufficiently high temperature in
this model it turns out that if i look
at the limiting free energy
it coincides with a conditional annealed
free energy where a condition on the
random mean of this distribution so so
this this identity will not hold if i
just look unconditionally at the
expectation of z when there's an
external field right but it turns out if
i condition on the mean it reduces the
fluctuations of z enough to make this
true
uh this expectation of the free energy z
given the mean is hard to compute and
understand um
and so the idea that both housing
introduced was as a proxy for computing
this conditioning on the mean we can
consider an amp iteration uh where the
iterates are um solving this parisi
potter's or okay and in the sk case just
the usual type equation um that
supposedly characterizes this mean
and as a proxy for conditioning on the
mean we can condition on the sequence of
amp iterates that converges to this mean
and the benefit of doing this is that
this
conditioning you can explicitly
characterize using the amp state
evolution
and you can verify this conditional
moment equality by computing also the
conditional second moment
so this was uh the idea that was
introduced by bulthausen
to provide an alternative proof of the
replica formula for high temperature
regimes of sk
and a related idea was also used by
ding and sun to study the easing
perceptron
so the algorithm that we study to uh
solve the parisi potter's tap equations
in the orthogonal varying context is an
algorithm that was introduced by
checkbox and oper in 2019
uh it's an algorithm of this iterative
form that you see here
it's it's a vamp style algorithm so it's
it's an algorithm that has this special
memory free structure
that i described previously
uh it operates um
the matrix that you multiply in every
iteration is not the couplings matrix w
itself but a certain resolvent of this
matrix w
and then you apply a non-linearity
that's a translation rescaling of the
tangent function
and you can check that
mt which is defined by tangent of h zt
in this algorithm would
converge to a fixed point of the freezy
potter's type equations um and in
particular this this so there have been
a number of uh different amp algorithms
that have been proposed for solving
these type equations and we chose this
one because of the nice structure of
this um
memory free structure that you get in
particular this asymptotic freeness
property of the iterates u with this
matrix w is really crucial to doing the
calculations in the proof
so to summarize the argument at a bird's
eye level then
we condition on a sigma field generated
by the iterates of this and p algorithm
up to large iteration t
you can write down explicitly the
conditioned
first moment let's say of the
partition function z
it takes this form
and then the conditional law of o is
conditioned on a linear event so it's
very easy to explicitly describe
it'll have a component that depends on
these amp iterations and then some
residual orthogonal randomness
and if you evaluate the expectation over
this residual randomness using an hcis
integral
and apply a large deviations analysis to
take the limit n goes to infinity
what you get is that this conditional
first moment
to lead to leading exponential order is
given by a maximum variational formula
right so there's some variational
function of psi
where if you maximize over some primal
variables u and minimize over some dual
variables v
it would characterize this this this
conditional first moment
okay and then for sufficiently high
temperature we could show that the
optimal value of this variational
problem is exactly the replica symmetric
prediction plus a discrepancy that
vanishes as you take more and more amp
iterations
and you can do something similar for the
second moment
so to conclude uh what i described is a
general amp algorithm that is available
for orthogonally invariant matrices
where you can define the onset or terms
in a way so that it still has a gaussian
state evolution
in an application the bayesian pca
we developed a spectral initialization
of this algorithm and we suggest a
full-based posterior mean non-linearity
to apply in every iteration
and this seems to empirically improve
over pca for non-white noise
and in an orthogonally invariant easing
model
this algorithm may be designed or
specialized to solve the freezy powders
type equations
and this can be used to prove the
replica symmetric free energy and high
temperature version
thanks very much these are the
references for the talk the first is
this is this non-rigorous paper by oprah
chuck mcinvinter and then the rest are
the um the results that i described
thanks
great thanks so i guess we had a bunch
of questions already but uh
two quick questions one is can you
remind us what hci z stands for i i
think i know what those
exponential integrals are
harish chandra ethics and zubair okay
thank you
um and
i i like the inductive proof
to the extent i understood it
but
when you say the upper chakra in winter
is not rigorous is that because you're
worried about error terms in the saddle
point method or
i mean
i had the impression that
saddle point and laplace methods were
sort of well controlled yeah i it's a
good question i don't know what it would
take to make that argument rigorous um
uh
i'm not sure but if if it's possible to
do i haven't seen it done in even the
gaussian case for just like the usual
gaussian amp
you have the same kind of argument but
i've never seen a formal proof that
takes this approach so i don't i don't
know i'm not super familiar with those
methods um i'm not sure
so you feel that's that's more than a
few
dotted eyes and crossed twos away from a
roof this is my sense but okay thank you
hey uh thanks so much for the talk uh i
was wondering for this spike pca kind of
problem right so
potentially given that now you have
these base optimal ap kind of algorithms
you can also predict what would be like
hard phases right algorithmically
so do you have any notion of what the
noise distribution might be which would
sort of create the hardest problems yeah
so let me let me just say we're not
we're nowhere close to there i uh this
algorithm i described i'm not claiming
it's phase optimal
i don't know whether it's base optimal i
don't know what base optimum error
should look like i think these are very
interesting questions in this model okay
um this is related to andrew's question
about the likelihood being
not a quadratic like sure
you know i think it's a super
interesting family of
questions there um
yes i don't want to i don't but but the
algorithm you described
that's not expected to be the base
optimal thing i honestly i don't know i
don't have a guess either way
it's something that seems to empirically
work quite well in a lot of examples
we've tested that's all i can say
uh great
other questions
if not let's think so again
so
we have a break and we're back in 30
minutes at 3 15.
yes